the only age just the first time I've
been 44 years old was kind of telling
you this earlier so you know what's the
difference like for you I can tell the
difference of what happened from the 20s
to 30s to 40s that's what I can talk
speak on like in my teens in the Army
energy going eating pizza you don't
worry about it nothing happens I can eat
two large pizzas in a night next day I
still have my six-pack it doesn't matter
right you know energy in the 20s and
then 30s flexibility 40s you know bones
back what what do you notice but also I
noticed with experience of negotiation
leverage you know how to go into
different board rooms how to read
different personalities on the business
end but what was the biggest difference
going from 20s 30s for was there
something that you can point to well
when you're in your 20s you think you're
going to live forever and you just uh
you know you can do anything you want
um but by the time you're in your 40s
your life pattern is largely set in
other words if you're 44 years old
you're probably going to be on a path
towards success or not success generally
entrepreneurs at 55 don't start new
companies and they change their life it
happens but generally not yeah so now I
read the reason I started Carlisle at uh
was I read that entrepreneur will start
his or her company uh between the age of
28 and 37. you know obviously they're
Mark zuckerbergs and Bill Gates
exceptions but 28 and 37 I read that
when I was 37. so I said I better start
something I'll never be an entrepreneur
interesting so you're Now 44 you're on a
path towards a certain level of success
and we continue this path no doubt in
your 50s you'll be even more successful
had you not started what you're doing
now and you tried to do this when you're
50. it might be harder to get started
because by then you've got kids are
older you got to deal with you've got
more financial challenges all kinds of
other things now you can get this going
but and you're on a path towards um you
know success when you hit 50. you know
that most likely you've lived more than
you're going to live and you have to
look at things a little bit differently
when you're 44 you can say well maybe
I'll make it to 88 so maybe I'm only
halfway through
um but you know people have uh you know
40th birthday parties that's when they
kind of say I'm really moved into
adulthood I'm really a real adult now I
can't pretend I'm a kid anymore yeah so
when you're 44 you know you're a young
on the other hand if you're a
professional athlete at 44 you would be
you know you'd be gone if you're done I
mean how many professional athletes
other than uh Tom Brady I'm Tom Brady
are there playing at any sports at the
age of 44 so while you're young looking
now if you're a professional athlete you
would be seen as too old yeah that'd be
uh being asked to being a head coach or
assistant coach or something like
hopefully if that's what you want to do
what to expect in 50s 60s 70s
well as you get older and you're
successful people will will uh I treat
you more with more respect presumably if
your success continues also you have
more of a responsibility to give back
you're going to Mentor people more and
more and ultimately you got to figure
out what you're going to do with your
wealth
um you can build a pyramid to how great
you are you can buy yachts and so forth
or you can give some of it away and you
have to figure out how do you want to
use that wealth in an intelligent way
and be a good role model for your
children
uh any any blind spots to look out for
any blind spots so be careful with this
be careful with that be careful with
this hubris you know when people tell
you how great you are you got to be
discounting that because very few people
are that great there are very few real
geniuses that are floating out there or
people that really change the world so
you know I mean you know Darwin may have
changed the world Einstein changed the
world but we shouldn't think that we're
going to be Darwin or Einstein just
because we made a lot of money got it
hubris I just read this book by Jim
Collins what's uh how the mighty not a
mighty fault and what was the first step
was it was number one number one hubris
is what causes people to uh to fall so
compounding the the other thing I want
to talk about is compounding you know
when you're you're really working hard
you're doing your part like oh my God
I'm so good like front putting so much
effort on the front oh first time I've
ever made a hundred thousand dollars six
figure oh my God like this is amazing
will I ever make a million I'm grinding
you make a meal but that's amazing I'm
making a million bucks I'm gonna top you
know half a percent of America this is
sick but I don't know if I'll ever get
to 10. you know will my business ever
get them some of them we got to 10
million dude but there's no way I'm
gonna get to the heck the side when did
you know like listen
the likelihood of me being a billionaire
in the next 13 years is very high your
math guys so far you've done a bunch of
different things that's math I said 1.8
2.2 you said combined we had 4.4 4.0 you
said 44 years old 88 50 you're not
thinking so everything in your mind and
I know you're a math guy yourself as
well but at what point did you say I
think I'm gonna be this within because
you're numbers guys so I know the
typical the humbles I never thought
about being a billionaire that was never
part of the goal I totally get that I
understand that's not part of the goal
but it is a milestone when did you say
at this point if I go at this rate we're
probably going to reach that number
probably when I was maybe 15 years in a
starting car I started when I was 37 so
probably when I was early 50s I said
okay this is going to be one of the
larger private Equity firms in the world
and as an owner of it I'll probably do
well but and I didn't obsess over it and
you know when Forbes puts out these
lists then people pay attention to you
so my children didn't really know the
level of my wealth until Forbes comes
out and publishes and that's true with
your neighbors my neighbors I'm going to
this I'm living the same house now for
35 years or so and people they don't
really know what I do that much and
maybe a little bit but you know one day
they might read the Forbes and say hey
this guy is worth X billions of dollars
and he's living on taking out his
garbage less like us so uh you know it
but in the end it's like anything in
life when you pass it through you go
into the next thing if you obsess over
being it now there are a couple people
who obsess over being on that list
um you know I won't mention them but
they're people who have sued Forbes for
not being on the list uh or not being
high enough on the list but if you
obsess over your numbers you know it's a
mistake you can't confuse your net worth
with your self-worth if you basically
just say I'm worth X dollars and
therefore I'm really great that's a
mistake don't worry about your net worth
worry about what you're really doing
with your life that's much more
important very interesting and yeah I've
heard the stories about people soon
Forbes for either being too low or too
high or you know not on the list not
right no not on the list but uh
interesting so what all the craziness
taking place I believe future looks
bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red our
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]